recuerdo la primera vez que vi un
murciélago tenía apenas seis años y una
persona um
vecino de la cuadra tenía un murciélago
sujeto sujeto en sus manos y en la otra
mano tenía un cigarro y trataba pues de
ponérselo en la boca
y nos decía mire ya ven los murciélagos
si fuman para mí eso fue muy impactante
lo único que yo veía era un murciélago
que estaba tratando de defenderse y
mordiendo el cigarro no fumando en ese
momento me di cuenta que muchas de las
cosas que nosotros creemos saber acerca
de los murciélagos no son ciertas
desafortunadamente muy pocas personas en
el mundo saben que los murciélagos son
muy importantes porque polinizan flores
dispersan las semillas de un sinnúmero
de árboles y arbustos tropicales la
mayoría de las personas piensan que los
murciélagos son animales rabiosos
animales asociados con las cosas
diabólicas nada más alejado de la
realidad
muchas de las cosas
que recuerdo de mi infancia de las cosas
más memorables de mi infancia han sido
en el arroyo en el río disfrutando con
la familia con mis hermanos con mis
hermanas comiendo taquitos atrapando
renacuajos
pasando un momento maravilloso en
familia es muy importante que
vayamos con nuestros hijos con nuestros
niños a llenarnos de naturaleza estas
experiencias de nuestra infancia son muy
importantes y son gratis lo único que
tenemos que hacer es llevar a nuestros
niños al campo y que descubran lo que
hay debajo de una piedra que escuchen el
canto de los pájaros que se nutran de lo
que mucha gente ha llamado vitamina n o
vitamina de naturaleza el crecer y el
estar en contacto con la naturaleza crea
personas más conscientes y
más
en contacto con la naturaleza y también
nos hace adultos más responsables del
cuidado del medio ambiente
en el mundo hay alrededor de 1400
especies de murciélagos y la mayoría de
ellos
pesan alrededor de 20 gramos la talla
promedio de los murciélagos es de 20
gramos esto quiere decir que necesitamos
alrededor de 5 murciélagos de talla
promedio para alcanzar el peso de lo que
es una barra de mantequilla sin embargo
el murciélago más pequeño del mundo pesa
apenas 2 gramos y el más grande
alrededor de un kilo y medio
desafortunadamente este murciélago
gigante por así decirlo está en peligro
de extinción porque en asia mucha gente
los consume como alimento no
en
y los murciélagos representan casi una
cuarta parte de todas las especies de
mamíferos que hay en el planeta muchas
personas piensan que los murciélagos son
ratones viejos y que son ciegos y nada
más alejado de la realidad
recuerdo que antes de que entrar a
estudiar la licenciatura en biología
recuerdo a la emblemática pues cueva de
la boca no en esta cueva siempre estaba
rodeada de mitos y leyendas por ejemplo
la de agapito treviño caballo blanco que
se refugiaba o que se escondía en la
cueva de la boca agapito treviño era un
bandido tipo robin hood mi abuelita
lupita decía que en la cueva se escondía
el tesoro de agapito treviño
después cuando empecé a estudiar a los
murciélagos me di cuenta de que el
verdadero tesoro que estaba escondido
dentro de la cueva de la boca eran los
murciélagos que ahí se refugiaban
quién hubiera pensado que ese niño
remojado que perseguía libélulas en el
lago en el río en el arroyo estaría años
después hablando sobre la conservación
de los murciélagos es muy importante
decir que cerca del 70% de estas 1.400
especies de murciélagos se alimentan de
insectos o sea son insectívoros los
murciélagos tienen un metabolismo muy
acelerado y requieren consumir casi su
propio peso en alimento por noche
entonces crea unas condiciones el tamaño
crea unas condiciones de requerimientos
energéticos muy elevados y un murciélago
por ejemplo puede comer hasta 1500
zancudos o mosquitos en menos de una
hora y un murciélago mexicano de cola
libre o una colonia de murciélagos
mexicanos de cola libre de 20 millones
de individuos pueden comer hasta 150
toneladas de insectos por noche imaginen
la cantidad de insectos que consumen yo
creo que apenas cabrían
en esta sala y cerca del 70% de esos
insectos son insectos plaga que atacan a
muchos de los cultivos más importantes
como lo es el maíz el sorgo el algodón
entre otros
es también muy importante porque estos
murciélagos ayudan a los agricultores a
que se arrojen menos pesticidas al
ambiente no tan solo en los eeuu
se ha hecho una estimación de que
alrededor de 50 mil millones de dólares
los murciélagos ayudan o ahorran a los
agricultores en pesticidas que se
utilizan para controlar a los insectos
también por otro lado los murciélagos
frugívoros dispersan una gran cantidad
de semillas de árboles y arbustos que
sirven para la regeneración de los
bosques y de las selvas tan solo un
murciélago de cola corta estos
murciélagos viven en el sur de méxico
pueden dispersar o diseminar hasta
20.000 semillas en una en una semana
alrededor de una semana imaginemos que
el que es lo que sucedería si una
colonia aún cuando fuera muy pequeña de
estos murciélagos fuera destruida o
quemada cientos de miles de plantas
dejarían de ser sembradas cada año y
alteraría en el delicado equilibrio
ecológico de una región
por otro lado los murciélagos néctar y
borox que se alimentan de polen y néctar
ayudan a la polinización de muchas
especies de plantas de importancia
comercial se ha estimado que alrededor
de 500 especies distintas de flores
dependen de los murciélagos para su
supervivencia entre las plantas más
importantes que polinizan los
murciélagos se encuentra el agave o
maguey del cual se obtiene el tequila y
mezcal es una planta emblemática de
méxico de la que se obtienen muchos
otros productos pero tan solo en el 2018
se exportaron de méjico
alrededor de 1200 millones de dólares
por tequila y por mezcal imaginemos qué
es lo que sucedería si estos animales
desaparecen pues muchas familias
dejarían o estarían en peligro esta
industria
completa de las casi 1.400 especies de
murciélagos que hay en el mundo
solamente tres se alimentan única y
exclusivamente de sangre y estos son los
llamados murciélagos vampiros
de estas tres especies de murciélagos
vampiros solamente una causa problemas a
la ganadería y es el llamado murciélago
vampiro común los vampiros se
distribuyen única y exclusivamente en
américa tropical desde el norte de
argentina hasta el norte de méxico los
murciélagos vampiros son muy raros en
las selvas tropicales en las selvas que
no están alteradas más sin embargo son
muy abundantes en aquellos lugares donde
la selva se ha destruido y se han
introducido ganado o son pastizales en
los cuales se ha introducido el ganado
por esto los agricultores los ganaderos
perdón tienen que vacunar a sus vacas
para evitar que sean infectadas de rabia
la rabia es una enfermedad
asociada con los murciélagos más sin
embargo la rabia es una enfermedad común
o exclusiva de los mamíferos los
murciélagos sin embargo no son más
rabiosos que otros mamíferos silvestres
como chorrillos zorros coyotes se han
hecho estudios y se ha encontrado que
menos del 1 por ciento de los
murciélagos en condiciones naturales
pueden estar infectados de rabia sin
embargo son los murciélagos los que son
mas satanizados y sus cuevas son
destruidas
en una ocasión
estaba dando una charla sobre la
importancia de los murciélagos y su
conservación y una persona un estudiante
que estaba en el grupo me dice para mí
tu plática no sirve de nada porque si
una persona que vive en un ejido o en un
rancho alejado no escucho lo que nos
estás comentando de la importancia de
los murciélagos y va y quema una cueva
pues ya valió no entonces yo me quedé
así como que enzo y dije pues
de cierta forma tiene razón o sea no
podemos evitar que los que una persona
vaya y quema una cueva más sin embargo
estamos creando una conciencia hasta que
no tengamos una conciencia colectiva en
la cual más gente sepa de la importancia
de los murciélagos es cómo vamos a
lograr que esto no ocurra ahora ustedes
saben más sobre los murciélagos sobre su
importancia y si ven por ejemplo a una
persona que quiere hacerle daño a un
refugio a una cueva no lo van a dejar
que lo haga o sí entonces si ustedes no
hubieran escuchado que los murciélagos
son importantes pues hubieran dicho que
bueno que los mataron o sea los
murciélagos son animales feos animales
rabiosos entonces es muy importante que
compartamos lo que hemos aprendido los
murciélagos han estado en el planeta
tierra por más de 50 millones de años
casi casi cuando
de dinosaurios desaparecieron los
murciélagos ya están ya estaban
presentes esto lo que quiere decir es
que han también desarrollado una gran
cantidad de interacciones y asociaciones
con otros organismos con su ambiente con
su entorno pues imaginemos qué es lo que
sucedería en el caso de que los
murciélagos desaparecieran hubiera
ocurrirían pues éste tendría resultados
insospechados que los murciélagos
dondequiera que se encuentren juegan un
papel muy importante en el delicado
equilibrio ecológico y ayudan a mantener
oa elevar la calidad de vida de todos
nosotros es también muy importante
recuerden que los murciélagos polinizan
flores controlan poblaciones de insectos
y dispersan las semillas de un gran de
una gran cantidad de árboles y arbustos
tropicales principal enemigo de los
murciélagos es la ignorancia
entonces lo más importante es compartir
dar a conocer lo que hemos aprendido y
con esto ayudaremos a proteger oa cuidar
a estos aliados invaluables muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]